es gibt aber auch orte die komplett
unter quarantäne stehen wo man also
nicht einmal mehr das haus verlassen
darf ein solcher ort ist neustadt am
rennsteig in thüringen und vor ort ist
jetzt unter kollegen und der uns davon
erzählt hallo
ja hallo hallo ins studio wir stehen
hier etwa fünf kilometer vor dem ort
kommen selber auch nicht weiter an
denn die das absolute geister stimmung
sie sehen dass er hier ist die
absperrung neustadt am rennsteig wurde
gestern abend komplett abgeriegelt
fahrzeuge durch sturm und lautsprechern
durch die stadt und verkündeten bitte
verlassen sie nicht mehr die häuser
jetzt ist schicht im schacht
und das liegt daran dass die zahlen im
kreis der kroner infizierten auf
insgesamt gestiegen ist davon kommen
allein aus neustadt am rennsteig sechs
personen und deswegen hat sich die
landrätin petra enders jetzt entschieden
ja eine komplette quarantäne des 900
einwohner ortes zu bringen das heißt als
wäre darf jetzt noch rein und wenn ich
tatsächlich haben nur rettungskräfte
pflegedienste die polizei und die
feuerwehr eine ausnahmegenehmigung sich
hinein zu bewegen oder auch hinaus aber
selbst die sind verpflichtet
schutzanzüge schutzausrüstung zu tragen
sonst geht auch bei denen nichts gibt es
irgend erklärungen dafür dass dort so
viele infizierte leben
tatsächlich gibt es einfach nach der
sich im ort die runde macht von dem wir
mitbekommen haben eine frau sei vor zwei
wochen aus dem urlaub zurückgekommen
seien
und sie steht jetzt unter verdacht den
virus bitte den ort gebracht zu haben
soll wo an der supermarktkasse
gearbeitet haben und dort sozusagen
dafür gesorgt haben dass die
vorbereitung relativ schnell um sich
gegriffen hat
allein jetzt wird von 69 personen direkt
gesprochen haben
dabei treffe sowohl für 960 personen
sprich das gesundheitsamt
mit denen diese personen zusammen
knacken kontakt sind also eine
verkäuferin soll es gewesen sein und das
ist natürlich echt ein ganz großer punkt
menschen für die es ja fast unmöglich
ist diese eineinhalb meter abstand
überhaupt zu halten oder möglichst zwei
meter die der völlig ungeschützt sitzen
und wo ständig leute vorbei gehen die
auch keinen mundschutz tragen also leute
die extrem exponiert sind ich habe
gesehen an manchen baumärkten zum
beispiel gab es plexiglasscheiben so
dass die verkäuferin irgendwie geschützt
waren aber in den meisten leben ist das
ja nicht der fall
wie ist denn da die stimmung sind die
leute extrem frustriert oder hat man
verständnis für diese harten maßnahmen
unserer ansicht nach müssen wir kommen
ja jetzt selber nicht direkt dran haben
auf und die betreuer natürlich auch dass
die situation sehr schwierig ist und das
ist ja ja sie machen es den tag 1 von 14
tagen
die situation macht den leuten sorgen
gerade weil offensichtlich die situation
auf den straßen im ort sehr gespenstisch
ist aber es geht jetzt vor allem darum
auch die situation wie sie sagen diese
menschen versorgt werden
da packt gerade die landrätin der
ilmkreis der krisenstaat sozusagen
versuchen die versorgung klarzustellen
es wird empfohlen dass alle erst mal zu
hause bleiben natürlich das licht und
alle die erkältungssymptome irgendwie
mit sich tragen sind jetzt verpflichtet
das telefonisch erstmal zu melden
ein beispiel stark auf von den elf
infizierten wurde ein mensch gestern
noch nach suhl in die klinik gebracht
der muss doch tatsächlich sogar an der
beatmungsmaschine versorgt werden